comment vous avez raté cette
condamnation
écoutez
j'ai été un peu surpris mais en même
temps quelque part je me félicite de
cette décision parce qu'elle montre de
manière magistrale la partialité
idéologique de la justice française je
m'explique où quand on pense qu'un
rappeur ni conrad appelé dans une de ses
chansons à pendre les blancs cg les
textes de la chanson ici c'est un
anglais un véritable appel au génocide
il a été traîné en justice par le
ministère de l'intérieur lui même qu'il
a été condamné à 5000 euros avec sursis
en première instance c'est-à-dire 0 est
totalement relaxé par la cour d'appel je
parle même pas des délinquants si vous
voulez qu'ils sont libérés ou condamnés
à des peines ridicules comme par exemple
ceux qui agressent les élus et qu'ils
sont libérés après un simple rappel à la
loi eh bien je me dis que il ya comme un
problème qu'est ce que j'ai fait au fond
il y avait un professeur qui s'appelait
didier lemaire qui dénonçaient l'emprise
islamistes à trappes qui est quand même
un secret de polichinelle ce qu'on se
rappelle que trap a fourni un autre pas
d'accord oui donc normalement le préfet
qui est représentant de l'état il aurait
dû soutenir didier lemaire puisque
didier lemaire et fonctionnaires et donc
ils représentent aussi quelque part
l'état or au prétexte que le préfet dit
avec les islamistes à trappes nous
faisons dans la dentelle et bien en fait
on découvre que le préfet et d'ateliers
avec les islamistes et se transforme en
bûcherons quand il s'agit de ceux qui
combattent l'islamisme d'accord donc
pour résumer cette histoire
je constate que
lorsque quelqu'un appelle un génocide il
est élargi un génocide sur la base de la
race salers point de donner ni conrad
est par contre
allumé un préfet sur twitter eh bien ça
vous coûte très cher je finis en disant
que le procureur de la république dans
un dans un réquisitoire absolument
hallucinant érable réquisitoire du sénat
défini hallucinante avait requis contre
moi la peine maximale c'est à dire 12000
euros 12000 aux achats oui donc donc
12000 euros pour un tweet 5000 euros
avec sursis pour un appel au génocide
donc voilà et ce réquisitoire est
absolument hallucinant parce que ce même
procureur me disait dans son
réquisitoire que j'étais au fond la même
chose que les trafiquants de drogue ou
les délinquants qui recevait dans son
prétoires alors nesrine qu'est ce tu
penses de ce que dit en fait à un moment
donné je pense que c'est mérité tout
vraiment parce que en fait twitter c'est
un espace public comme les autres et sur
twitter on se doit de se comporter comme
on se comporte dans la vraie vie et on
est forcément puni pour ce qu'on dit sur
twitter et moi ce qui me choque c'est
votre facilité à utiliser des mots très
graves comme islamistes soutien aux
islamistes sans preuve sans rien et ce
préfet dans son bon droit tout
simplement de réclamer justice et de
réclamer à ce que en tout cas ils soient
pas attaqués comme ça publiquement sur
twitter sans preuve donc c'est normal la
justice et c'est ça sert à rien de
comparer avec d'anciens le cas qui sont
peut-être plus grave peu importe il a
quand même à votre votre casse etc il
est important parce qu'il est médiatique
vous êtes quelqu'un de très médiatique
longtemps parce que madame nous
entendons comme adam donc je comprends
de votre propos que la justice en fait
ne vous condamne pas pour ce que vous
faites mais pour ce que vous êtes et
vous mes vaches et j'ai envie de la
contre que vous dites aussi je suis ravi
de l'apprendre non mais je pense que
c'est un oui mais justement moi séoul et
je suis à la fois chroniqueur et
polémiste donc j'ai léger le droit à la
liberté d'expression en respectant la
ligne et je peux vous dire que j'ai
failli aller j'ai failli être condamné
au maximum il a fallu il a fallu toute
l'expérience et la compote combativité
de mon avocat maître ludovic de villèle
pour ramener de 12000 euros à 1500 euros
la peine l'appel que l'oeuf à lever le
verre le verdict c'est vous dire à quel
point la justice est particulièrement à
la main à la main particulièrement
lourde lorsqu'il s'agit effectivement de
personnes qu'elles considèrent que
certains juges rouges ou roses considère
leur ennemi on vient de propagande notre
public ans est condamné il a mieux
l'armer la justice et archilla archives
non messieurs vous pourriez pas faire
preuve parfois une fois dans votre vie
de modestie belge où en étais je vous
avais déjà que les parents revenaient de
prendre une barque de la justice a dit
ward injurié après fès a du sens que
vous êtes condamné pas du tout le
procureur admirable je vais lire ce
qu'il a dit tu vas bien sûr à l'egypte
en can ya des virages comme vous dans la
ville il a dit que l'adil posait un
homme qui passe son temps dans des
salons confortables et que jamais vous
n'allez sur le terrain nous insulter un
préfet qui fait tout ce qu'il peut à
trappes afin de suivre les années mais
sortez un peu aller où logeront t à la
vraie vie taisez vous arrêter avec tout
ça ce sont des invectives et de
permanence en est mais de quel droit et
pas assez cher et vous qui faire le sale
ona carbonell aurions 12000 euros
j'aurais aimé
qu'ils ne connaissent que cugnaux que 5
à travers des bandes dessinées pour nous
donner son arrêt tgv aux jantes ok
d'accord avec jean bessière pain bah moi
je suis choquée parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui quoi qu'on
dise et qualifié d' insulte de
provocation d'injures et ça me choque
d'autant plus que twitter ça fait des
années qu'on nous le vend comme un lieu
de liberté d'expression totale sans
aucune censure mais là on voit que ce
n'est pas le cas il ya une autre
question c'est si ce tweak lavaud 1500
euros que valent tous les autres tweets
conlie raciste antisémite de menaces de
mort ces gens là ne paye pas 1500 ou
2000 euros d'amendé moi j'en mets siècle
les autres et elle est d'accord pas qu
elle mais bon c'est bien moi ce qui me
choque vraiment c'est que je comprends
plus rien ce pays c'est qu'effectivement
on voit un môme qui crie mettez vos
gilets pare balles à la vôtre bas
j'arrive il prend cinq jours de rappel à
la loi ça ça paraît tout à fait normal
c'est vrai rappeur sous prétexte l'autre
jour on avait booba beaucoup de respect
il a beaucoup de talent mais il ya des
textes homophobe misogyne mais ai dit je
suis artiste donc en fait jamais ça
aurait dit remarqué par certains d'avoir
son twitter by joue à marseille ça rien
à voir non mais à partir du moment où
des artistes ont besoin mais si c'est à
dire les la vôtre ou même
si c'est un rappeur blond avait appelé à
prendre les noirs ou pendre les arabes
ou fondre les juifs c'est pour ça rien
tu que tu crois vraiment que la justice
leur élargie comme lee conrad ben voyons
pourquoi dieudonné et condamné alors
dans ce cas là il est artiste non alors
ça vous maintenant d'avoir pareil c'est
pas des ajustements sicilia les deux
artistes et pas dans des sacs sur i'm
too et sakho bredouille pourquoi il est
condamné ben c'est ce que disait alors
il sait ou
pas pardon mais comparaison n'est pas
raison donc cesser de vous qu'on parle
de qui ça non mais
en dix ans lui il a pris dix mille moi
j'ai pris deux mille l'autre il a pris
trois mille peu importe les caprices toi
mais les quatre sur les cas sont
différents et ce n'est pas grave et moi
moi ce qui m'interesse là c'est de
savoir si on commence on pas à régenter
sa fille était le farwest fil twitter
aujourd'hui maintenant il commence à y
avoir des comptes des condamnations qui
font office de ce sanction pour dire
attention warning plus comme avant on
peut le dire tout et n'importe quoi on
peut commencer maintenant a modéré ses
propos nous aurions pu d'ailleurs parce
que jean messia vous êtes vous vous êtes
même au tribunal excuser de vos propos
de la façon dont vous allez voir mulet
banon non attention vous allez on remue
les non non j'ai dit simplement que moi
j'assume mais mon tweet mais que si
effectivement moi je ne voyais rien
d'insultant de ce que j'ai écrit mais si
effectivement ça a été pris comme tel je
m' en effet blessé mais je ne m'excuse
pas sûrement laissé bien seul sur la
scène qui est d'accord avec michael youn
les uns et les autres maintenant même si
on veut dire qu il des choses on peut
les dire de différemment sans injurier
sans invectives et sans lui demander
jamais dire à quelqu'un qui n'a pas gêné
tu peux le différend le monde est
radicale
satis aujourd'hui il ya deux poids deux
mesures moi je suis très choquée que
maintenant j'en messia reçoivent une
condamnation voilà à 2000 euros c'est
pas un délinquant mais le chien contours
voilà bah non il va lever le pied sur
les coussins etc
celui-ci
va pas le droit de le voir chez kiabi
celui-ci alors
[Rires]
est-ce que tout simplement ce n'est pas
un délinquant c'est un polémiste et un
polémiste il y a des gens qui sont en
accord avec lui et des gens qui ne sont
pas d'accord c'est le principe du
polémiste qui est ouvert clivant mais
alors un final en pâture à des moyens
trouve ça bien malgré tout que twitter
aujourd'hui c'est un peu régulé c'était
le far west
ouais enfin et il ne va tomber d'injures
d'insultés de menaces pas mon cas non a
attendu un petit voleur vous avez quand
même utiliser la collaboration des
préfets jimenez heures
si vous tombez sous le coup de la loi
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un légaliste
on attendait d'abord elle évite moi ok
ludovic butelle a interjeté appel donc
la condamnation n'est pas définitive
elle cette semaine et ont trouvé 500
balles
voilà la gauche qui ce jour monté en de
leur immeuble étoile à l'amont à 5000
voilà
dans une salle d'enchères ont pris moi
je me suis à vous respecter quand même
les institutions de notre république
c'est pour ça que je c'est pour ça que
je n'interjette appel mais les
institutions de la république cela vous
savez je vous apprends pas quand même
que la justice dans ce pays elle est
politisé et des syndicats de la bonne
attaque route et l'appelle
souvent chemin de fer interjeté par
nadal
appel à la justice est politisé et des
syndicats qui ont des couleurs
politiques affichées quand un syndicat
je n'aime pas appel à voter contre
sarkozy par exemple en 2012 il fait de
la politique et les eaux partait place à
la banda les emplois vous sortez pas
leurs primes je suis tout à fait
d'accord que effectivement il faut qu'il
faut que les effets des réseaux sociaux
soient régulés mais convenez quand même
que ce que j'ai écrit convenait ne n'est
pas n'est pas de ce qui est plus grave
de danse maorie sur twitter
à tout un tas d'insultés racistes et
j'ai dit oui mattrick wargon qui le kg
marine et manu s'ils vont ou maghrébine
et arabe de service est bien curieux
charge de chamois là et de chameau il a
même pas été a banni de twitter lorsque
vous dire pourquoi vous portez pas
plainte voilà que moi je considère si
vous voulez que le débat public c'est
pas de la pénalisation de la pensée ici
comment je réagirais je refuse de
rentrer dans cette logique raison
quelqu'un effectivement et tenter accord
avec moi même s'ils l'expriment de
manière virulente je lui réponds mais on
est bas même si le débat peut être
parfois viril costaud outrancier même
bug dans le cas d'un de ddd polémique
parce que la polémique est à la pensée
ce que la caricature est au dessin c'est
pas interdit vous comprenez oui donc moi
je je je je je veux que les choses se
passent en dehors du cadre de la loi
après maintenant bien sûr et quand il ya
de l'antisémitisme le met sa vie était
là mais là c'est pas le cas
d'isabelle morini oui parce
qu'effectivement le préfère parfaitement
le droit d'attaquer donc là moi je
réponds oui ce sont pas là pour le reste
sera entièrement d'accord avec la reine
didon alors non parce qu'ils les
comparons pas comprenez vous que jean
méchas ce qu'on ait la vie sociale
lourde amende non je me plaît venez la
position du mec c'est entièrement mais
on se place de là les ont battu
nicker les flics et qui vole le camion
dans le camion de pompier ne soit pas
condamné dans quelle position
delphine toi qui connais bien les
positions et donc
[Rires]
c'était la vidéo qu'on avait vus sur le
gène qui mais je sais que j'ai compris
je suis pas complètement
mais c'est ça qui est incroyable en
france quand je disais les deux poids
deux mesures
serge elle n'aura rien du tout n'aura
rien du tout et encore une fois jean
messias et on n'a rien à craindre de lui
il ya quelque chose aussi c'est que je
rappelle quand même que c'était la
première fois de ma vie que je me
retrouve dans un prétoire est hors jeu
mais un début à tout alors je constate
les délinquants que vous défendez
monsieur verdez lorsqu'il s'agit de
primo délinquants ont dit ah non il faut
qu'il y ait de la clémence parce que
c'est la première fois
bizarrement cette clémence neuf non
seulement elle n'a pas joué en ma faveur
mais au contraire on a ri grand requis
contre moi le maximum mais pas si vous
êtes si vous êtes normalement constitué
psychiquement vous
vous êtes attaqués aux préfets à
l'autorité de l'état après des attaques
et aux reproches et les six mois par les
seconds arrêtez de vous écouter vous est
pénible les islamistes
les islamistes ont un ami wisa le préfet
mais ça vous aurez à vous aussi c'est
pour ça que vous dites ça
ça s'emballe dans ta gueule messia
c'est l'autorité de l'état que vous avez
voulu la paix en faisant du préfère bien
sinon c'est pour ça les 12000 euros
attend six fours seront plus jamais plus
jamais vous le disiez ça et à
juste titre je le prends le prof dédié
le maire il représente l'état ou pas le
prodige est lent mais bien du tout et il
fallait il représente pas l'état dans ce
qu'il a dit sur trappe mais il regardera
était de faire un double
à midi à tomber juste arrêté à la montée
des amis des islamistes si j'avais dit
amis des amis des communistes 6 2,6
demain dans le cadre d'une manifestation
car il y en a rien à voir quelqu'un qui
investissent attendez il ya quelqu'un
qui est issu de la diversité qui traite
un préfet de fasciste et arrêté croyez
sur la diversité assumée pour une
générosité
arrêtez arrêtez assumez vos erreurs
ll des fondations une association cisa
très très un préfet de fascistes elles
n'encourent strictement rien alors que
le mot fasciste est tout aussi
insultants clamé oui oui et pourquoi
vous avez été banni de twitter alors si
j'en sais rien alors je vous l'apprends
j'ai gelé a pris - lieu avant-hier le 16
il y à une séance en référé devant le
tribunal de paris pour vous voilà contre
twitter c'est le mon avocat gilles
william goldnadel qui me défendant cette
même année c'est devenu de plus en plus
difficile d'exprimer une pensée avoue
que l'avocat me louer
le système que je combat va se defendre
vecchio parce que comme il n'a plus rien
à dire sur le fond eh bien il va essayer
de vous deux vous verrouillez sur la
forme c'est pour ce soir le coup d'envoi
a conservé ce soir oui vous voyez pas
que monsieur messi est en train de jouir
ensemble parce que c'est un des mystères
cette fois ils cherchent un prétexte ne
te mets pas en faire de moi alors parce
que tu risques de subir les conséquences
[Applaudissements]
on est miss chaque fois comme ça
lui retourner sur la fin à lire aussi
les jeux montaleau des limites elle est
alors mis d'entrée dont louis non mais
c'est tombé et familiarité alors c'est
ça c'est un polémiste et tous excédé de
gens qui vous levez la main pour dire
oui juste une démo bout de phrase ça
m'amuse et de dire qu'il était en train
de jouir à d'accord
un jour ça sera quoi ça non pas quoi
c'est pas mais ils prendront des screen
j'ai même pas envie de rajouter ça parce
que c'est grave de passer d'un débat
aussi sérieux quand on parle justement
d'attac public et d'en finir avec un
repas c'est sûr qu'au boulot vous êtes
bien placé pour savoir si elle va vous y
avez travaillé madame à la droite
mais je vais l'inviter téléspectateurs à
aller voir ce que c'est le bondy blog
ensuite on aurait plus il y à travailler
mais attend avec des minorations
mouvement nationaliste et le bondy blog
et justin médias moi j'estime qui a été
créée après 2005 dans wii et 20 13 on
parlait de la vie des personnes issues
de quartiers mais déclassé votre compte
ou pas pardon mehdi m'éclate oui c'est
quoi le rapport avec le foot mais c'est
pas le rapport avec le vous le savez
très bien c'est quoi c'est quoi le
rapport avec avec le bondy blog et avec
ma canne mehdi meklat qu'était au bondy
blog aussi oui et comme badroudine comme
y'en a plein et même les sommets
classique et défavorablement connu des
services comme on dit c'est quelqu'un
qui a été
la vache r non mais d'accord mais ne
venez pas donner des leçons d'accord et
me regarder de haut et faire comme si
vous étiez et faire comme si vous étiez
une procureure de la sainte inquisition
médiatique mais ceux ci ont fouillé rien
dit d'accord mais
aujourd'hui on va papa lé là on n'est
pas venu pour ça et c'est assez ridicule
c'est juste et simple sur messia vous
conduisez un véhicule oui je vous ai vu
je vous ai croisé dans la rue c'est
votre femme qui conduit des oui c'était
moi je suis un fervent partisan de
l'égalité hommes femmes
vous étiez en train de vous la couler
douce à côté non c'est ça l'égalité des
bus vendredi ça lui manquait ouais je
devais passer et d où sa femme le
conduite tranquille eu trop de gens voir
mes emmerdes non non non non il avait
une petite voiture alors franchement une
petite voiture une petite voiture non
mais c'est vrai vous conduisez sinon
c'est important mais c'est où je le
savais j'ai mon permis de conduire
depuis l'âge de 18 ans faites gaffe les
sièges vous allez y
faites gaffe on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs tiens 34%
65% ne comprennent pas que vous ayez été
condamné apparemment voir quoi
[Rires]
m